hi this is presh talwalkar
how many squares are in this picture
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
one way to solve this problem is by
counting the number of squares very
carefully
we'll remove the two squares that are in
the middle to be left with a four by
four grid
now we'll count the number of squares of
different sizes
there's exactly one square that's four
by four that's the big square and then
we'll count down the number of squares
of smaller sizes
the number of three by three squares can
be found that they're two squares per
row and we can count this for two
different rows so there's two times two
or four different squares of three by
three size
how many two by two scores are there
in a given row we can place three two by
two squares
and there are three different rows that
we can create squares so there will be
three times three which is nine two by
two squares
finally we count the number of one by
one squares
there are four different squares in a
row and we're going to have four
different rows that we can do this so
there will be four times four which
equals sixteen one by one squares
we now place the two squares in the
middle back together and we count the
number of more squares that they add
the number of big squares that they add
in the middle will be equal to two
and now they'll add some salt small
squares in the middle
each of these squares is going to
contribute four more small squares and
they're two of these so this will
contribute eight more squares in total
we add up all of these numbers and we've
counted that there are 40 squares in
this picture
did you figure it out
now there's a shortcut we could use if
we're going to do problems like this
if you have an n by n grid there will be
1 squared plus 2 squared plus all the
way up to n squared number of squares
we found this already that the number of
four by four squares was one which
equals one squared the number of three
by three squares was four which equals
two squared
the number of two by two squares
remember there were nine because there
were three squares per row and three
rows and the number of one by one
squares was 16 because there were four
per row and there were four rows
we could have started out by counting
this without even doing the count of the
squares just using this formula and then
we would have had to add on the number
of squares created by the squares in the
middle which would have been 10 and that
would have again got us to the answer
40.
so you could intuitively see why this
formula is true you count the number of
squares created per row and the number
of rows you have but let me just provide
another proof we'll use induction so
we'll assume the formula is true for n
and we'll prove it's true for n plus one
so we have an n by n grid and we're
going to add on one by one squares on
the side so that we have an n plus one
times n plus 1 grid
by the induction hypothesis the n by n
grid has a total number of hidden
squares of 1 squared plus 2 squared all
the way up to n squared number of
squares
so now we need to see the number of new
squares we can create by the scores
we've added on
we first count the number of one by one
scores we've added on
you can count this by saying there's n
plus one squared minus n squared or two
n plus one squares
another way to see this is you're adding
on
n plus one squares to the the row n plus
one to the column but the one in the
corner is going to be mutual so you have
two n plus two minus one which is again
equal to two n plus one
now you want to count the number of two
by two squares that you can create
this will be two fewer and the number of
three by three squares will also be two
fewer and this pattern continues and you
can add on exactly one square that's
size n plus one by n plus 1.
so the total number of squares we can
add on is the sum of the odd numbers up
to 2n plus 1
and that's a well-known formula of n
plus 1 squared
so we've added on a total number of n
plus 1 squared number of squares so in
total in an n plus 1 times n plus 1 grid
we have the same formula plus n plus 1
squared and that completes the induction
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel and make videos
on math and game theory you can catch me
on my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description